[Music]
i think if this next thing were to
happen here it would be a total [ __ ]
show
but um taiwan did a pretty good job
taiwanese news accidentally reported
that they were being invaded by china
what a little that's oopsie that's a
little bigger holy [ __ ]
they said jk
yeah
was it was it digital or was it like
newspaper you know it was digital it was
actually on the chinese television news
what was the picture i was like
apparently it was a ticker you know like
the new stickers
yeah so they they actually ran the wrong
news taker which i think is meant for
drills
so it's like the simulation they're
saving that for like six months from now
it's like they're not gonna do this
another six months yeah but listen to
this this is what the tickers actually
said it said the chinese communists have
stepped up their preparations for war
and um it says new taipei city has been
hit by missiles from the communist
military taipei port has exploded
facilities and ships have been damaged
it is suspected that enemy agents have
arsenized and planted explosives at
bangkok train station what if it's
what if they already knew this was gonna
happen and then they just had that ready
to go to hit yeah dude this happens like
six nine months from now that's spooky
dude that's gonna be freaking weird very
spooky yeah
dude so imagine reading that or imagine
seeing the american version of that when
you're just like watching the news and
it just starts saying the statue of
liberty has been decapitated
sounds like a movie
part two i feel like the people now be
like man i hated that statue
yeah anyway how do they do that
shot into the sky during a bombing
you think americans would freak out
probably oh yeah oh absolutely i just
can't imagine it on our soil even though
it's been like will pearl harbor 9 11
happened but then war isn't so close to
home right war is something that you you
you destroy a third world country like
doing that not like here you know
the closest thing that's happened at
least in our lifetime is like
terroristic attacks but not like all out
like no invasion right because people
would be stupid to invade america
because not only the military's strong
but there's a ton of citizens with guns
dude you come to la the gangs alone are
all strapped up you know no wait they
gave all the guns back because it's
illegal all right at the gun drive yeah
they gave it back
the buy back drive yeah the buy back
turn in your guns i hope the asian hate
people are really productive like if we
get really invaded by china those guys
better be the first ones over there yeah
but this is the problem with america
they saw dumb we need the compton gangs
we need the bloods and the crips to come
help out in the west coast
be at the real asians over there
i'm american dude dude there's tanks on
one side there's like six four impalas
on the other side
that is so difficult
dr jane eminem's performing on top of a
tank
[Music]
dude in war they would stop during
christmas have you ever read uh
stories of war time world war ii they
everybody stopped fighting during
christmas to observe christmas so
imagine everybody stop beyonce is going
to perform we'll get back to killing
each other in about 30 minutes oh my god
we don't watch beyonce or black friday
we all need savings right yeah
we'll stop the shop
and and if you shop on our camp it's
tax-free
[Laughter]
do you think they would ever do stuff
like that again like actually honor
these like war codes
yeah because like if when you look at
the ukraine russia stuff they didn't
follow nothing it's just like all war
crimes all around yeah they're bombing
civilians man that's crazy i don't even
know i can't see christmas breaking that
one up i think christmas can do the
power christmas
you don't underestimate the power of
christmas
europe takes christmas so seriously they
don't [ __ ] around chris like we take
christmas like we kind of like larp
christmas like they take christmas like
seriously we have a coca-cola christmas
what do we got we have polar bears
drinking coca-cola christmas yeah do you
think that like gentlemen's
a word like that honor that culture
still exists i think it's all espionage
and war like i don't think because back
then it was like we're two gentlemen we
can agree to not fight you know and then
like it's like i don't know if that like
that type of like masculine like i'm a
man you're a man like we can you know i
feel like it's like this guy turns
around
we gotta stay ready i thought it was
christmas
you promised
i thought we were friends for this week
i gave you a present yeah
it's just a hole in the back stabbing
[ __ ] i gave you that knife that you're
stabbing me with try this jack in the
box i swear that's all it is
[Laughter]
russia wins
over that jack-in-the-box yeah i don't
think uh i feel like that whole era of
like pride in being a gentleman is
gonski i think like once it leaves
social
i feel like the social norm you know
like how for the longest time there was
always like pushback about like women
not wanting men to do like chivalrous
things yeah and i feel like wait that's
the thing yeah
yeah i could open the door by myself
thank you that's right
even if you don't like personally i've
never encountered that myself but just
knowing it exists made me more careful
like i don't want to interact with
strangers that i don't know in that way
anymore but before it was cool to do
that like just to
be nice you know i think it's a myth now
you just only the elderly get that now
dude i forgot to open the car door for
my wife the other night she gave me the
death stare she's like are you not going
to open the door for me like oh
sorry i mean yeah
let's touch the other side and open it
for me yeah yeah dude you're a man dude
closes the door for her dude
and then closes it right before she
walks in
here that's what the conflict is between
like trying to support
feminism but at the same time like
that type of male role like it's kind of
weird it's like okay is it so it's
offensive to do that but i open the door
i keep the door open for everybody like
i'm walking through and most people are
very yeah i do it for everybody anybody
can get it do you go to the other side
and open the car door for her sometimes
if she's being nice to do a whole lot if
she deserves it yeah if she's you know
she's a whole lap and a half and then
you do it yeah yeah yeah yeah i run
around and i fake her out
and i walk it back to my side
you thought i was on the door for you
it's not it just doesn't seem cool to be
like a gentleman anymore in any like in
any popular media other than not only do
you got to open up the door i think you
should open up the door get a get a
footstool try and put that [ __ ] on there
so she can step you are the footstool
[Laughter]
that old thing with the coat that would
be dope dude that's a myth nobody did
that yeah can you imagine these days
there's a puddle you go you want me to
put my supreme jacket on the puddle for
you yeah
but this is 1200 on the aftermarket
i know the travis scots right the pain
of a flipper doing it
man the resale
my supreme umbrella no i'd rather get
wet
it takes the value and down in half
it's crazy our valleys change like a
[ __ ]
what's that show like like if you watch
like peaky blinders like you watch that
show and it's just a novelty that
they're that like gentlemanly which is
weird it's like i wonder i wonder though
because they still had espionage and all
that but i think it's because they were
um
they all fought under the same conduct
or like for example it's like austria
hungary versus spain or something or
like you know it's like two european
powers
same kind of set of rules but then if
they
if they're colonizing they don't use
that same rule to go against natives or
whatever
genghis khan or whatever yeah like if
they're going in it's like it doesn't
different rules right and then and then
if you're two countries that observe
christmas they're more likely gonna
share that common thing right but if
it's like if they're going to [ __ ]
[ __ ] up a buddhist country or a muslim
country they're like christmas
oh you're gonna chill all right [ __ ] you
i'ma [ __ ] you up there yeah that's true
so i think everything turned into like
guerilla warfare and like every man for
himself it's like a different tactic
everyone's trying to be a ninja these
days you know i think the ninjas
originated that navy seal [ __ ]
and now everyone's trying to fight like
a ninja but you gotta think there's
normal people in the army too right
because they say we get drafted like if
i have to like kill a kid i don't think
i'm gonna be able to do it you know and
he's the enemy that's technically
against the rules though yeah oh is it
oh it's against the rules you can't kill
kids and children are women wait they're
doing that now they are oh
technically you're not supposed to check
but you're not scoring points over it
yeah yeah it doesn't look like a
scoreboard you know if a dude's like
begging for us like dude i got a family
i got kids i'm like
fudge so do i dude yeah i was like fudge
you know this is funny why am i even
here are you training were you trained
for that type of thing no they don't
turn you can't those things it just the
fish shows up it shows up when you do
the rehearsals there's not like a person
on his knees
please please
yeah i'm only
and i'm english
in korea
[Laughter]
please don't kill my kimchi farm
now he sounds like boring
very nice there's no training for like
when people try to pull like an
emotional ruse right i mean i'm sure for
like those special forces people they do
yeah there's there's um they're surveyed
like they're talking to a lot of like um
assassins right like whether they work
for mercenary or like the government or
they're like working for the mob and
then they say what are some funny things
or like just odd things that happen some
quirky things that happen yeah a lot of
work
what does a zenith work
[Laughter]
tell me one fun fact about being an
assassin you know
it's your most favorite killing i know
so one thing that that makes a lot of
sense but we don't we all don't think
about it he goes like a lot of people
when they're begging for their life they
go i have family i have kids don't do
this right and then but they always like
thinking well
we've had bad
families that's why we're here and we
also think that
it's a favor to the kids to take your
ass out
because then you're a shitty father
right you're not this patient i'm doing
them a favor and so he's like that just
makes him want to kill him more right
and i'm like what that's such a
my fault because you wouldn't even be in
this situation if you were a good dad
yeah cause they're usually killing like
drug lords dictators or just like shady
characters and then they do profile on
them they're like oh this guy's a serial
rapist or whatever they're like at the
mo last moment they're like i have a
family with kids and they're like oh
they're better off without you imagine
trying to gauge it though you're like
how many different mothers
he's like i have seven baby mamas
public or private school
like it's you're getting really into it
name their middle names yeah yeah
what are their birthdays and he's like
oh [ __ ] do you ever see those tick tocks
where they ask the moms and dad stuff
yeah yeah like they're like the dads
guys don't know anything there's like
four kids they're like what's the color
of melissa's eye it's green and then
like what's your eye color blue and the
dad's like oh [ __ ]
stop taping
i don't know [ __ ] they don't know the
name of the school yeah the school they
don't know
best friends
that could happen with uh with you with
you and tyka in any way where you
wouldn't know something that i mean i'm
definitely dumb as a dad for certain
things
because i compartmentalize stuff and i
think i think that's the difference
between guys and girls i think girls
it's like they memorize everything at
the same time
for dudes it's like
i don't know where the [ __ ] the soap is
i know where my wife knows where the
soap is so i'm out of soap i go hey babe
where's the soap she's the soap person
she's a soap person right file it under
that right yes it's one degree away from
your own dude my dad he met he he saw
this lady at the store and he started
talking to her
and then he goes home to my sister and
he goes hey i saw your roommate today i
started talking about the at the
supermarket and she's like
who like whitney and he goes
oh and he realized he was talking to
some random lady who he thought was my
[ __ ] suspect
at least she was talking to him he was
like all right see you later
ladies and gentlemen
i don't know who the [ __ ] that guy is
you guys are going to be so polite
so ridiculous that's just bad [ __ ]
though isn't it this is bad [ __ ] war
dead [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you